hello everybody and welcome to the 9th
TV basics tutorial video in this video
we're gonna be talking about a couple of
things one is the screen manager will
just barely touch on that before moving
into it the next video as well as the
Builder which will be the primary focus
of this this video so once you start
building a large enough application
whatever the framework you're using is
you're gonna find that you're gonna need
a fundamental thing and that's to move
between windows basically or be able to
change the screen so you need to be able
to have the user you know say click on
settings and settings menu pops up or
you know navigate between I don't know
various types of Windows and this is
actually traditionally kind of difficult
especially unlike tkinter if you recall
in pygame the way that we do it is just
by cleaning the entire slate and then
redrawing on it with tkinter we have
basically all of the windows in the
background and then we load the one that
we're most interested in at the moment
make that on top basically how keavy
works but luckily TV wrote that code for
us on like tkinter which we had to kind
of write the code so anyways let's go
ahead and talk about those two things
but mainly we're going to talk in this
tutorial video about the Builder so the
idea of builder is so with these key v
files we saw that basically we have to
have that key v file at least besides
app this word is needs to be the word of
the key v file and i don't really like
that i think that's kind of messy and at
least is especially here where we're
changing like say versions and stuff
like that um it gets kind of tedious and
annoying that it's not really explicit
it's almost like an implied kind of
thing where it just needs to be
basically like the root of app needs to
be the word it's just kind of messy I
don't really like it so anyways uh there
is another methodology to bringing in
key v files and that's with the Builder
so I'm gonna delete basically all of
this code here really I guess we'll
leave that and we'll leave that but
basically all of this code now you might
want to leave it here because we're
going to come
- this little widget we're going to use
it again in a little bit but I'm trying
to make sure we pair everything down to
the most basic values so when we add new
things you understand where the
fundamentals of those new things so I'm
going to delete everything basically up
to here and we'll leave the main app now
the next thing that we're going to do is
instead of in fact what we can't what
I'll do now we'll leave it sorry so the
first thing we want is builder now we
have to import that that's not something
that just like naturally comes with key
or naturally is imported with say app of
key V and so what we're going to say is
from key V dot Lang imports builder and
then we're just we just need a reference
builder and so we're gonna say basically
like this you would say for example
we'll say presentation since the kini
files really are just your presentation
I like to use the word presentation
equals builder daunt load underscore
file and the file we want to load is
just the name of that KB file in our
case I've called mine main dot TV that's
this file here so now that will blow
that file in and it really doesn't
matter what the name of this class is
really so that's basically it the only
other change you would really need to
make is you would take presentation and
have it return presentation now there's
really nothing to this application we
don't really have anything here at the
moment so we're gonna have to add
something here so presentation has
something to present but I did just want
to cover builder before we hop into the
next next thing which will be the actual
screen manager but to use that we're
also going to use builder and that
should help me moving forward with these
tutorials a lot easier because I kept
forgetting to change this name and this
name and it was quite annoying so
anyways that's it for this one real
quick simple tutorial with Builder
before I guess suppose before we move on
I will just say that builder you can
also do instead of load file give you
something like load string
and you could load the string like so so
you could have your triple quotes here
triple quotes here and then you could
basically copy and paste your key D file
right in there so like this and that's
completely acceptable that would work as
well with key V I'm not going to really
do that I don't feel like that's you
might as well just write it in Python if
you're gonna do that
uh so anyway I'm not really gonna do
that I like the load file better I think
that's pretty pretty good idea so
anyways that's what we will do moving
forward pretty simple tutorial but if
you do have any questions or comments
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support subscriptions
and until next time